-I feel as though every time
you come here, the joke is
we never have anything
to talk about in politics.
And yet here we are again.
-Yeah, here we are again.
It gets better
and better and better.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-It depends on
how you look at it.
-Yeah.
-But yeah.
So, I mean, I don't even quite
know where to begin.
But it does seem like
how quickly even
the Republican Party
started framing
that there was nothing wrong
in the asking for a favor
in an upcoming election abou
your potential opponent
from a foreign government.
Are you shocked at how quickly
they've tried to reframe thi
or is it just
par for the course?
-Well, I think -- Look, we all
feel like we've lost our minds
This is the prevailing political
feeling of the last 2 1/2 years,
is that it's making
people crazy.
It's very hard to concentrate on
any one thing.
There are individual tweets,
for example.
Presidential utterances.
What was the one yesterday where
he described himself as --
-Oh, yeah. "With my great" -
-"My uncommon wisdom
and unparalleled."
Can you imagine if Barack Obam
had done that?
-Yeah.
-Like time itself
would have stopped.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Clocks all over the world
would stop running.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-This happens -- you know,
somebody says something
on a morning show
for two seconds
and it's on to the next thing.
The key thing here is that the
President of the United States
tries to enlist foreign powers
to eliminate who he thinks
is his strongest
political rival.
And that's not completely
dissimilar from Watergate.
In Watergate, if anybody's old
enough to remember what it was
was that the President of
the United States
was in a conspiracy
to destroy his --
what he thought was
his strongest political rival,
Edmund Muskie, in order
to run against the weakest one
in his mind, George McGovern
And by the way,
he won 49 states.
He got exactly what he wanted.
But he didn't go to the troubl
of enlisting China,
Ukraine, possibly Great Britain,
Italy, and all the rest.
This is beyond our ability
to imagine.
And the Republican leadership,
for the most part,
although maybe that will chang
with time, I think, you know
until public opinion
changes really markedly,
they're not gonna budge.
-Yeah.
-And that's, to me, tragic
-One of the stories or I shoul
say one of the avenues
they're taking towards
explaining his behavior
is that he's joking.
When he says,
"I want China to interfere."
-You know, he's never joking
-Yeah.
-Have you ever seen him laugh?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
And I spent an entire week
with him
when he hosted
"Saturday Night Live."
[ Laughter ]
-And he never laughed.
-He never laughed.
-No, I don't think
he really has a sense of humor
except in a kind of sadistic
crush-an-ant sort of way.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Like that
that's a funny thing.
I've seen him -- I saw him
a few times, like,
nod when other people
laughed at something,
as if his brain was saying
"Oh, that's human humor."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Humans like this is a thing
-No, you used to see him -- He'd
do Letterman and other shows
And he kind of tolerated
the laughter from the audience
He just -- That's not a thing.
Look, he -- All of the scandal
of Nixon took place in private
-Yeah.
-He knew enough to conceal it.
To say horrible things
in the Oval Office.
Thank God
there was a taping system
and that's what
brought him down.
Almost everything that's
going on with this president
is right out in the open.
His way of denying that he sai
these things to Ukraine
was to say,
"Let's get China to join in.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it sounds funny,
but it's unbelievable.
And this happens
every single day.
-I wonder if, you know,
because it seems like anytim
we even talk about impeachment
it immediately goes back
to the history of '98
and Clinton being impeached.
And ultimately the fact
that people will say
he ended up more popular
via impeachment.
-His popularity was
pretty good going in.
-Right. Oh, yeah, that's
a big difference. Right.
-That was a big difference
What seems to be the case with
Trump is that he has this core
of somewhere between
38% and 42%.
And you cannot win an election
on that.
You cannot even survive
impeachment necessarily.
But the circumstances
are different.
What makes it different that
Trump's ability to hold on
to his core may be
longer lasting
because he has a media complex
that speaks to that core.
Right?
-Mm-hmm.
-It has Fox News and other
things on social media
that speak directly
to that core.
If you watch those things,
they're saying something
radically different
than CNN, MSNBC, "The Times,
"The New Yorker," whatever
They're saying things that are
to my mind,
fantastical and untrue.
But they are saying
those things.
Now, if that begins to crack
if that -- if Fox News,
and you're starting
to see it a bit,
begins to recognize realit
and actually broadcast it --
If some senators,
like Senator Romney from Utah,
if that core begins to expand,
then things could change.
Public opinion could change.
The political dynamic
could change.
-You spent many years in Moscow.
-I did.
-You wrote an incredible boo
about Russia.
I would imagine
you have an affection
for Russia
and the Russian people.
-I do.
-Yeah, I mean, it was --
-I do. I was there as communis
was declining and collapsing
And then I kept going back
as this new,
whatever you want to call it
began to accumulate and develop.
-Do you -- Having actually
been there in this moment
where there was
maybe this other path
that Russia was gonna take
and I think a great optimism
to what Russia was gonna be,
and I know we've spoken
in the past about you having
sat next to Putin
at a dinner party once before.
Are you kind of shocked at where
this is and disheartened?
-I think you have to
compare Putin
to a guy who's playing
in a poker game.
And he's got two threes.
And the United States
has three kings.
And other countries have
other similarly large hands.
And he outplays them.
-Yeah.
-This is not a great economy
This is not
a stable political system.
It's all built around one guy,
which history tells us
is not gonna last forever.
But his ability in whatever role
Russia played, for example
in our last election to fermen
chaos in our public life -
He is laughing hystericall
into his sleeve.
-It helps him that our president
is holding his three kings
facing out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So that everyone at the table --
It's making it
a little bit easier.